I'm telling you Matt unlived things
change gonna make a ton of money and I'm
gonna have everything that I want living
things college like thousand bucks now
you're in business kit or you some kind
of loan shirt I'm a businessman
you want in yeah I wanna buy the money
don't limit to what I can do
see what I'm talking about I mean you
tell you the checks from the north which
account haven't cleared yet if I write a
check from that account into the second
account I can cover my shorter it's
called check kiting it's illegal does it
matter
look everybody thinks I'm some kind of
hotshot now I gotta keep that long this
is called restoration work the insurance
companies contracted out to restore it
you make
we need to find a way to fake some
non-existent restoration jobs talking
about hundreds of thousands of dollars
and jobs that don't exist
we split product 5050 can I trust him
absolutely your stock is worth 100
million dollars I had everything I ever
wanted until it all came crashing down
yeah yeah
Special Agent gamble FBI you can't climb
out of this one Barry you have no idea
what it takes to build something you
don't have anything because you don't
have God I'll by God you are hereby
ordered to serve a term of 25 years in
jail
the church has five million dollars
parked in a money market the perfect
ingredient for the successful Ponzi
scheme
for once in your life don't take a
shortcut
you're running the scam you really try
to change your life was it just another
Berryman you're asking me to give the
carpet guy just bank statements for five
million dollars where my grace
you